[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time to see what is
making the headlines with the political
editor of the daily mirror bakura and
the political editor of the sun harry
cole welcome to both of you and i know
you're with us till just before midnight
so front pages let us start with the
financial times it leads with the
announcement that nato will increase its
forces on high alert sevenfold
the metro's front page reports on the
missile strike on a shopping center in
ukraine with their headline shoppers
murdered by russia
the sun also leads with that story
calling it horror at the mall
the telegraph reports that the head of
the armed forces will say that britain
is facing its 1937 moment and must be
ready to fight and win to ward off the
threat from russia
the guardian leads with reports that the
prospect of a strike grows as doctors
eye a 30 pay deal
daily mail also with that story on their
front uh their headline doctors demand a
30 pay increase well a reminder that
we're scanning the qr code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages and the ones still
to come in uh while you watch us so
let's bring in our guests then pippa
carrera and harry cole who are joining
us with the latest stories including
pippa front page of the metro and a
number of the other newspapers about
this awful attack on the on the shopping
center and president zielinski
suggesting that a thousand people might
have been inside and uh you know what
this means in focusing efforts of those
g7 leaders who've been meeting in
germany
yeah and it's absolutely horrific news
that broke this afternoon we've kind of
become used to this too in some
awful way the attacks on ukraine from
russian missiles but this is obviously a
unequivocally civilian target there's a
shopping center in the middle of the
afternoon packed with women and children
up to a thousand people
and
it's been targeted by russian uh in
eastern ukraine targeted by russian
rockets in some way from the front line
it just shows really the might of um of
russian uh aggression and um
the
social media scenes were horrific it was
people at the shopping center um show
recording it on their phones
and
the building by the end of it was
absolutely raised to the ground i mean
you got awful images there
um so far the death at all 13 people
killed by 58
but the ukrainians have warned that that
is likely to
to increase um to increase over the next
few hours um it's you know zalensky is
described as an act of terror it's been
condemned by the united nations and it's
very striking that this happened when g7
leaders amongst whom are prime minister
joe biden as well and others who have
been the most critical of vladimir putin
for his actions um in ukraine we're
gathering at the g7 summit um harry is
obviously there over in germany and uh
has been covering it and um in some ways
it's hard to kind of escape that feeling
that it was in some way intended to send
a message to those leaders that were
meeting mean they they've responded very
forcefully which i'm sure harry would be
able to be able to tell you more about
uh yes indeed well let's before we do
that let's just take a look at the
inside pages of the sun in fact murder
at the mall
and i'm just saying that the the former
russian president dmitry medvedev has
been uh speaking according to various
agencies the one i'm reading is the
reuters news agency uh saying that
russia will strengthen its border if
finland sweden joined nato they also go
on to talk about crimea and say if any
attempt is made upon crimea by a nato
country it will be seen as a declaration
of war on russia which could lead to
world war iii now this of course is all
ahead of the nato leaders meeting we've
had the g7 they go on to this nato
leaders meeting with this idea of
massively ratcheting up uh the the
soldiers um you know airmen etc harry
put on high alert uh in readiness um you
know it's it this war might be several
months in but the tension is still there
is it not
yeah but i think there's no coincidence
i think between what happened um this
morning at the g7 where president
zielenski
addressed the leaders privately he he
urged them to help him um finish this by
winter um to avoid the russians having a
tactical advantage in the cold and then
a couple of hours later jen stollenberg
the nato chief stood up and said as you
rightly pointed out we're increasing the
nato troop readiness on the on the
eastern flank on the russian border from
40 000 to 300 000 troops and they
actually declared russia the biggest
threat to the security alliance which
somehow it ended up as some sort of
strategic partner since the end of the
cold war but no now back to very much
being on the enemies list
and
yeah lo and behold just as those air
strikes happened on kiev last night for
the first time in a fair few weeks um
this horrific attack happens on a
civilian uh civilian uh infrastructure
um
privately it seems like that they're not
gonna publicly point the finger and say
it happened at the same time and it was
all linked but
privately they are suggesting there is
clearly a very suspicious link there and
boss johnson i understand told the
fellow leaders that
it was a stupid thing for putin to have
done because all is gonna do when
they're literally sitting around a
circular table together trying to
trying to you know hold a united line
all it's going to do is make the west
even more bound to ukraine there's a
really surprising thing that has been
here
uh in germany i'm actually in austria
because they keep it so far away from
the summit we're actually in a different
country um but what has been amazing
this week is normally these these these
summits tend to
end up with a bit of a bickering on the
sidelines rows here and there now i'm
not saying there's no disagreement
between these world leaders but they've
been at pains not to talk about
contentious issues that there aren't
between these two countries so they can
put on a united show and it's clearly
rattled the um the mad man in the
kremlin
and and the importance of um you know in
effect beating russia for its deterrent
value is on the front page of the daily
telegraph pipper
which is this idea that ukraine is our
1937 moment you know the pre-war crucial
moment
and this is the general sir patrick
sanders the chief of the general staff
who will say that britain must be
prepared to act rapidly to contain
russian expansionism i mean again you
know i reiterate this all sounds
extremely serious so patrick will say
deterring russia means more of the army
ready more of the time and this goes
back to that you know the high readiness
that we talked about uh with harry
yeah and um it comes after uh general
lord danette who was the former head of
the army saying that the cutbacks that
have taken place so the british armed
forces are untenable obviously we are a
major contributor to nato um and we're
one of the leading military powers in
europe in our own right as well so um
there's there's some concern
amidst the british military that
actually spending has not been
increasing at the pace that it might
that it might want to be and um for
example there's currently 82 000 troops
in the british army
they're due to decrease to 72 500 by
2025 and our battle number main battle
tanks going down from 227
248 and um
the defense target obviously that we've
committed to the two percent of gdp is
part of our nato commitment uh ben
wallace is apparently writing privately
well not privately since it's the
newspapers but um is writing to rishi
synax chancellor to say that they're in
real danger of missing that and there's
a real sort of pressure for a hike um a
hike in defense spending at a time where
frankly we're facing we're facing some
type of conflict that we haven't seen in
europe for many many decades yes and the
times goes on uh also to quote the head
of the british army uh telling soldiers
to get ready and train hard for war with
russia as cyber capabilities will not
help them to cross a river i mean it's
back to the old day of conventional war
isn't it um they also quote uh the prime
minister insisting you know that uh
president putin will pay for his
barbarity
is there a sentence there at all that
boss johnson is the one beating the drum
hardest on behalf of the ukrainians
there or you know that unity you talked
about is it really writ large from uh
from what you're hearing
yeah no there is no doubt that that boy
johnson has been
leading the charge so to speak um from
here definitely with the french and the
germans um he's been absolutely boiling
in this hotel room with no air
conditioning upper upper mountain about
35 degrees um yes he is he is leading
the charge and i think it's what is very
clear and becoming very obvious tonight
is there's going to be a spending
announcement i believe at the nato
summit there's no way that bargains will
be able to go shake the tin tell
everyone else that they have to
meet the commitments and when actually
because of inflation the defense
secretary has warned the chance that as
pippa said we will miss our spending
commitment target so it's very clear i
think that boris johnson is going to
have to say something about defense
spending perhaps not set out exactly how
much but definitely signal that britain
will be increasing spending and i
suspect we'll do that from the platform
in madrid um where we go tomorrow all
right so yes i was going to ask you
you're heading off to nato presumably as
well are you i read that uh britain is
hinting it could boycott the g20 summit
in november if putin was invited you
know this this idea that he needs to
continue to be ostracized um to allow
the penalties of sanctions um and public
opinion to work against him um but
obviously the big debate tomorrow will
be what happens with those nordic
countries still trying to join harry
what what wriggle room is there do you
think to to win over the turks or is
that what's been happening in the
background yeah i think there'll be lots
of i mean most of the time the most the
most
interesting summits is what happens on
the fringes the is the bilaterals that
are around the edges of the meetings and
they will increase dramatically i think
um once uh once sort of 30 countries are
there here rather than seven or eight
here at um here in bavaria um so i think
there will be meetings i think boris
johnson is meeting with the finns and
the turks and um you know trying to work
out exactly what can be done now
turkey's in a position it has been quite
resolute um on the war in ukraine it is
shut the black sea is patrolling the
black sea it is selling these brilliant
uh bacca bakurata jones i can't exactly
not exactly sure on the pronunciation
there these cheap very very effective
drones of actually enabled zalensky's
forces to have an um
almost a better advantage in the air
than expected if um
than the the russian air force and so
there is movement there but obviously i
expect there'll be a lot of horse
trading behind the scenes a lot of
haggling and now the turks will extract
quite a big price for for um expanding
nato and you know the backdrop in the
context of all of this uh pippa is
raising energy costs um you know a lot
of it blamed also on on the war there
um there's the rising food prices as
well and the concern of the ukrainians i
suppose that that pressure uh will force
some nations to pull away and uh insist
on them suing for some sort of peace um
so that you know that the backdrop is
that it affects every single one of us i
guess
it's very striking that boris johnson
said today in one of these many uh media
interviews that he did that it was a the
piece in europe is a price worth paying
um or rather that the price that we have
to pay for peace in in europe is worth
it um and that that was very clearly a
reference to the impact of um ukraine
crisis on fuel prices energy prices
there's a knock on
a knock on food prices as well of course
are there other factors there as well um
there are i think sort of the estimate
is about 80 of our inflationary pressure
is from international factors much of
that not exclusively obviously because
of china and supply chains and so on but
much of that is of course from the
as a result of the ukraine conflict um
what's going to be interesting to see is
that while barcelona and other leaders
are saying the same thing in their own
countries um what appetites or uh what
patients their own their respective uh
populations have uh when the cost of
living crisis really starts to bite
whether they think that actually the um
the focus should be much more on on sort
of helping them through that i mean what
the governments would say um is that of
course there's a link between the two
that you're not going to be able to
solve as it were the cost of living
crisis if you don't also address what's
going on in in ukraine but um
populations when they're feeling the
pinch i think will will be much more
focused on domestic matters rather than
international ones and that's a
challenge i'm sure that not just johnson
other leaders as well will have to face
in the coming months we'll stay there we
will um let harry open a window if that
if that helps i'm not sure
uh but also thunderstorm outside okay
that won't help
we'll move on to the inflationary
pressures though that we of which we
just talked about the prospect of more
strikes growing as doctors look for a 30
pay increase that and more after this
break
[Music]
let's return to the press preview then
joining me once again the political
editor of the daily mirror peppa creera
and the political editor of the sun
harry cole who joins us near but not
that near uh garbage parking where those
g7 leaders are meeting in a very hot
hotel room he tells us because it's
stormy there but let us go on to uh
domestic matters uh strike action by
barristers today now the prospect of
strike growing as doctors eye a 30 pay
deal harry this is in a number of
newspapers as well the pressure grows
does it not
yeah it was never going to just be the
train drivers and the railway workers
this was always going to be a sort of
sum of this content because behind the
scenes uh various pacers the public
sector are being negotiated
at different times and actually
um
other sectors have seen how the
government have reacted to the
um to the rail strikes which is to sort
behind know gently increase the offer uh
of pay uh pay pay settlements uh and i
suspect this will see you know many many
other sectors um out on strike um this
summer the problem is is that
the railways and the hospitals and and
various other sectors like that have
only really just started to recover from
from covid the teachers for example you
know kids who have already been have the
last two years of their education
disrupted face more disruption uh in the
classroom because of a pay dispute at
the moment the government is standing
very firm it's being very noisy and
saying no we're not going to bow to
pressure let's see how that looks when
schools are shut trains are on strike
doctors no one can get a doctor's
appointment and hospitals backlogs are
growing even more in six months time i
suspect it's going to get quite quite
heated quite quickly yeah just got a
minute left and i apologize i'm doing
these stories the wrong way around this
is the next paper is the sun written by
harry cole uh which suggests that uh
ross johnson is hinting at a second fuel
duty cart um pippa i don't know if you
can tell me about harry's story i do
apologize
well unfortunately i've read it i'm sure
harry could do a better job but
his story is that boris johnson has been
hinting today that after the fuel duty
cut of five p per liter in march
um the government is suggesting that
there might be more help to come but the
suggestion for number 10 that that
support would remain under review i mean
we've heard a lot of promises about help
to come and um
after since the big announcement that we
had a month or so ago um i think we'll
have to wait to the autumn for more but
suggestion of the sun seems to be that
while wholesale prices of oil as we all
know have dropped slightly the prices at
the pump remain at record highs and fuel
duties and fuel companies rather under
huge pressure to pass on some of those
savings um to motorists the treasury
obviously also takes a huge amount of
proliferating 82 pence per liter and
duty and vat for fuel and all at the
same time people are filling up their
tanks and and regularly finding that
that you know a tank of petrol is
hitting 100 quid or more depending on
what sort of car they have
uh feeling the pitch in other areas of
the life as well government's promising
to do something about it so let's see
sorry to russia we've had very little
time left thank you both very much
indeed uh peppa carrera harry cole thank
you both very much indeed